[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60 18 26 minutes pour
faire le tour de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de
cette édition du mercredi 27 mars saint
quentin en yvelines va modifier son père
lui plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal
une révision allégé afin de préciser
certaines règles et permettre de
nouveaux projets hier une réunion
publique se tenait à la salle du conseil
communautaire pour présenter les
évolutions et échanger avec les
habitants
magie et danses malgaches au programme
de cette soirée vendredi au théâtre de
la grange à bois d'arcy elle est au
profit des restos du coeur des yvelines
l'occasion de parler de leur actualité
sur ce plateau des représentants de
l'association et des magiciens du coeur
qui se joignent à cet événement enfin un
projet fou qui aurait pu voir le jour
dans les années 1930 faire de l'étang de
saint quentin une hydre aux bases
autrement dit un aéroport pour hydravion
françois dany des amis du musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines il
revient dans son livre l'hydro base
internationale
il est notre invité une réunion publique
donc sur le plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal hier soir les habitants
des sept communes historique de saint
quentin en yvelines étaient conviés à
l'hôtel d'agglomération
au programme de la soirée échanger sur
la révision de ce document cadre du
territoire les précisions de marylène
yapi chine son élaboration avait débuté
avant la fusion alors que saint quentin
en yvelines était à cette commune un
plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal qui
nécessitent d'être révisé de petites
modifications avant l'élaboration dans
un second temps d'un nouveau paix lui à
12 dont la réflexion pourrait commencer
en 2021
il ya très peu de modifications puisque
c'est une révision allégé donc les trois
grands axes du pays à l'ue l'économie
générale du ps lui lui tout est prêt à
être préservée c'est vraiment une des
modifications
d'écriture réglementaire des
modifications de zonage à la marge
c'est l'augmentation de protection
patrimoniale sur sur certains secteurs
et puis la préservation amendé centre et
hameaux pour eto'o identifié comme un
peu fragile après une présentation les
habitants pouvaient échanger avec les
urbanistes autour des cartes et des
documents de cette première ébauche de
paix lui
les habitants doivent connaître les
évolutions de leur propre territoire de
façon à pouvoir amener leurs pierres et
leurs remarques
on peut aussi avoir oublié des choses
ont bien les habitants peuvent ne pas
être d'accord avec les évolutions qu'on
propose donc c'est un moment
indispensable
l'objectif est d'arrêter le projet pour
le conseil communautaire du 27 juin
s'enchaînera une consultation des
personnes publiques ses associés puis
une enquête publique pour son
approbation en janvier 2020 c'est des
choses
voyez qu'on n'a pas forcément
quand on n'a pas forcément accès dans la
vie quotidienne et qu'une réunion
publique permet de
d'apporter de devoir j'étais intéressé
parce qu'en fait ma maison et se trouve
classée donc elle maintenant elle est
protégée par ce nouveau pays chaque
habitant peut faire part de ses
remarques dans les registres des hôtels
de ville 17 communes en écrivant
président de l'agglomération ou bien en
envoyant un mail à l'adresse
spécialement créée
il ne vous reste plus que quelques jours
pour vous inscrire sur les listes
électorales afin de pouvoir voter aux
européennes ces élections sont
programmées le 26 mai prochain en
plateau pour parler or ils iront demain
soir de la rédaction de tv 78 alors pour
les retardataires qui ont jusqu'au 31
mars minuit quelle est la démarche à
effectuer pour s'inscrire
alors vous avez deux options soit vous
rendez dans votre mairie avec une case
identité récente et un justificatif de
domicile soit et bien vous pouvez le
faire directement en ligne
ça se passe sur le site du service
public cela ne prend que quelques
minutes
c'est un scrutin qui mobilise peu qui
est aussi mal connue à quoi servent ces
élections européennes alors on rappelle
les élections européennes ont lieu tous
les cinq ans et permettent aux citoyens
des 27 états membres de choisir leurs
représentants au parlement européen en
tout 700 cinq eurodéputés seront élus
dont 79 pour la france c'est simple de
plus sans que qu'en 2014
conséquence évidemment de la sortie
normalement bien sûr du royaume goût de
l'union européenne et pour ce scrutin
aurélie une nouveauté une seule et
unique circonscription il ya cinq 5 ans
notre pays avait été découpée en huit
circonscriptions régionales met donc
pour 2019 ce n'est plus le cas chaque
parti politique doit présenter une liste
de candidats pour l'ensemble du
territoire français vous allez voir
d'ailleurs le nom des têtes de listes
s'afficher alors bien sûr nous n'avons
pas pu tous les maîtres il y aura
notamment manon aubry pour la france est
soumise le versailles et françois-xavier
belani pour les républicains nicolas
dupont aignan pour debout la france
yannick jadot pour europe ecologie les
verts ou encore l'ex ministre désormais
elle chargé des affaires européennes
nathalie l oiseau qui conduira la liste
est la république en marche
sachez qu'à l'issue du scrutin les
partis ayant obtenu plus de 5% des
suffrages bénéficieront d'un nombre de
sièges proportionnel à leur nombre de
voix et notez également que le début de
campagne officielle de ces élections
européennes débutera en france le 13 mai
à nice
si on rappelle également aurélie cette
date butoir ce 31 mars à minuit pour
vous inscrire sur les listes électorales
merci pour ces précisions dans
l'actualité également en première
ébauche pour la carte scolaire des
yvelines la direction académique et les
représentants des professeurs et parents
d'élèves ont travaillé sur le dispositif
pour le premier degré à retenir 72
ouverture et 87 fermetures de classes
pour le moment prévu et des effectifs
d'élèves en baisse -0 28% il devrait
être 148 1310 à reprendre le chemin de
l'école en septembre 50 postes
d'enseignants devraient être créés et 48
pour les dédoublements de classe s'est
élargie à l'ensemble des cp et ce1 de
l'éducation prioritaire
l es deux postes restants seront dédiés
à l'enseignement spécialisé pour les
enfants handicapés une carte scolaire
qui doit être affiné et d'ici la rentrée
ces travaux ont débuté courant en
février le cimetière de la verrière va
être réhabilité plus paysage est plus
vert il va aussi connaître une
rénovation de ses allées objectif
faciliter les déplacements notamment
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite le
reportage de nicolas landry une
pelleteuse des graviers et des marquages
au sol les travaux de rénovation du
cimetière de la verrière sont lancés
depuis un mois un projet mené par la
commune
après plusieurs demandes de la
population les allées n'était pas
conçu pour les personnes âgées et les
personnes handicapées
on revoit toutes les toutes les voix que
l'on peut faire à pied et qu'on pourra
désormais faire en fauteuil roulant
pour des personnes qui ont du mal à se
déplacer cette rénovation des halles est
l'occasion aussi de redonner un nouveau
visage à ce cimetière des années 60 plus
de fleurs plus de gazon et plusieurs
nouveaux aménagements
le monument aux morts va à bouger il va
être au bout du cimetière
dans la perspective de l'entrée cette
petite maison là on va y mettre un toit
qui continue avec des fleurs au dessus
et qui va être la nouvelle entrée une
entrée qui sera automatique vous avez à
les huit places et quand tout ça sera
fini on en aura plus une bonne vingtaine
coût total du projet cinq cent quarante
et un mille euros la moitié financée par
la région 20 % par le département et le
reste par la commune
la fin des travaux est prévue pour le
mois de mai première commémoration
célébré dans le nouveau cimetière
le 8 mai 2010 neuf solidarité c'est une
soirée au profit des restos du coeur des
yvelines magie et d'onze du coeur
événement a retrouvé ce vendredi c'était
au théâtre de la grange à bois d'arcy
pour en parler autour de la table trois
invités christian de coups de 9 rebonds
soir voussoirs bénévole aux restos du
coeur de bois d'arcy de niveau var bon
soir bonsoir vous êtes le président de
l'association les magiciens du coeur qui
se joint à cet événement également
rivale bonsoir bonsoir responsables des
manifestations pour les restos du coeur
des yvelines alors ça nous permet aussi
de parler un petit peu de l'actualité
des restos du coeur
et forcément cette 34e campagne d'hiver
qui s'est achevée pendant le mois de
mars
quinze mille bénéficiaires étaient
attendus par les restos du coeur des
yvelines quel est le bilan est blessé on
a fait ce qu'on avait prévu
quinze mille bénéficiaires de ce qu'est
un peu plus que l'année dernière
c'est un peu pas et 5% de plus alors
qu'au niveau national les restes du
coeur c'est la stabilité ce qui est
enfin on regrette alors préféré avec sa
baisse mais bon c'est une stabilité et
un nombre de bénéficiaires qui augmenté
dans le même temps peut-être des crise
de vocation du côté des bénévoles moins
de bénévoles
les bénévoles n'ont aussi c'est
relativement stable mais on cherche
toujours des bénévoles surtout dans des
métiers pointus métier comme chauffeur
à l'entrepôt cariste comme des
administratifs dans la communication ou
ses recherches quoi et donc si vous avez
des vocations si les restos du coeur
vous intéresse vous êtes les bienvenus
et bien sûr on peut retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site des restos du
coeur des iv après la campagne d'hiver
il ya aussi une campagne peut-être que
l'on connaît moins que les
téléspectateurs connaissent pas c'est la
campagne d'été des restos du coeur
absolument maintenant tous nos centres
sont ouverts aux non seulement l'hiver
mais aussi l'été et cette campagne va
débuter avec l'approvisionnement qui a
été fait grâce à la collecte nationale
qui a eu lieu début mars
et là je dois remercier l'ensemble de la
population des yvelines qui a été
extrêmement généreuse puisqu'on a
collecté 200 tonnes de marchandises lors
de cette collecte nationale le début
mars
mais pour financer aussi les actions des
événements bien sûr comme cette soirée
qui est au programme à bois d'arcy
vendredi avec de la magie et des danses
malgaches auraient présenté le programme
dans un instant christian de coup de
neuf quels sont les buts de cette soirée
à quoi finalement vont servir les fonds
que vous allez récolter les fonds seront
sûr surtout servir donc pour les restos
qui en ont besoin je crois que c'est là
c'est la priorité
on n'a pas besoin que de nourriture il
faut de l'essence pour les camions il
faut des deux des loyers pour les
locations de quelques donc on a aussi
besoin d'argent donc la collecte
nationale c'est la nourriture et un peu
d'argent mais on fait des spectacles
pour récolter de l'argent bien entendu
en plus des dons qui nous viennent des
particuliers des associations
donc c'est une forêt qui se prépare avec
notamment les magiciens du coeur qui
argument la première partie de la soirée
c'est votre association de niveau voir
pourquoi vous joindre à cet événement
est le monde de l'association est un
un petit monde où tout le monde se
connaît donc qu'on nous a sollicités
pour participer à la soirée des restos
du coeur et sans les plaisirs qu'on va
présenter deux de numéro une
un numéro de d'illusions de grandes
illusions et un numéro de mentalisme par
deux des membres des magiciens de
l'association il nous avait préparé un
petit tour qu'on va boire dans un
instant un petit mot de présentation sur
les magiciens du coeur vous intervenez
dans le milieu hospitalier
alors les magiciens du coeur le fond de
notre activité c'est d'intervenir dans
le milieu hospitalier
principalement en pédiatrie auprès des
auprès des enfants malades et donc vous
faites ce qu'on appelle du close-up les
petits tours vous en avez préparé à être
close up à l'abri gorille je voulais
avoir le plaisir de vous apprendre à
compter magiquement jusqu'à 3 d'accord
doit compter jusqu'à trois russes cadres
alors je vous montre déjà il ya combien
de ben ali
donc il y en a trois c'est pour
apprendre à compter jusqu'à trois alors
général l'allodynie les fous mais
regardez le shampoing je la mets dans la
main la deuxième je la mets dans la main
la troisième je la met dans la poche il
y en a combien de la main 2 dont grégory
je suis en train de vous apprendre à
compter jusqu'à trois noms je vais vous
demander de faire un petit effort
j'en prends de d2 je les mets dans la
rue main la troisième je la met dans la
poche et olé quand viendra la main mais
toujours deux normalement grégory joseph
est impliqué une dernière fois j'en
prends 2 d2 je les mets dans votre main
la troisième dans votre vol y en a
combien haut la main dès la 3 allée dire
quoi maintenant que vous savez
donc c'est le genre de tout vous pouvez
faire c'est john dieu fait en close up
et sur scène bien sûr c'est des grandes
illusions qui sont qui sont très très
spectaculaire et très bluffant
justement là pour ce cette soirée vous
le disiez le programme c'est l'illusion
plus tôt et l'illusion un programme les
manies magique ce qu'ils vont faire de
l'illusion autour d'un thème des dés à
jouer et gontran 2000 elle un magicien
qui est qui est mentaliste et qui est
passionné par le mentalisme donc qui va
bluffer tout le monde
mais christian de coûts de notre
deuxième partie de la soirée qui est
dédié à la culture malgache et donc non
plus on présentera des choses très
variées très coloré et puis aussi très
joyeuse donc surtout avec des des chants
et des danses malgaches dont qui
reprennent un petit peu les traditions
des 22 régions qui sont à madagascar
on aura aussi des sketches sur la vie
quotidienne
on apprendra à saluer applaudir à la
malgache
on apprendra aussi tout certaines
subtilités on se demande souvent
pourquoi les noms malgaches sont si
longs donc je ne vous le répondrai pas
ce soir mais vous le ferez à gérer voilà
tout à fait donc on apprendra aussi à
danser les danses malgaches en venant
sur scène avec notre troupe constituée
de 22 artistes d'accord donc onze
garçons et on suit à peu près donc
et on apprendra aussi quelques mots
essentiels de la langue malgache com com
tougas où je ne vous ferai pas l'injure
de vous demander ce que ça veut dire
sinon bienvenus d'accord bienvenus
bienvenue mitzah schuchat ça veut dire
merci et vélo enfin plein de mots à
apprendre
pour participer à la soirée ce qu'il
reste encore des places il reste
quelques places jeu auquel je crois donc
à prendre soit directement le soir au
théâtre ou également sur le site donc
des restos du coeur qui s'affiche
accueilli sa fille bonne les france
la billetterie a retrouvé sur ce site
internet des restos du coeur des
yvelines merci à tous les trois ans
rival christian de coup de neuf et
le niveau marre d'être passé sur ce
plateau une soirée au profit des restos
du coeur donc ce vendredi à 20h et c'est
au théâtre de la grange à bois d'arcy
petite pause culturelle à présent dans
ce journal avec le retour des beaux
jours les bourgeons fleurissent c'est
sur ce thème du printemps qu'on
travaillait à les élèves de l'école
d'arts d'elancourt pour leur nouvelle
exposition à l'occasion du festival
courants d'art ils ont pensé écrit
autour de la forêt patrick jacques de
dixmude et mélanie poké des histoires
des aventures les élèves de l'école
d'arts d'elancourt ont fait beau jaune
est leur esprit autour d'un univers
celui de la forêt
c'est un thème qui se prête bien à
l'environnement naturel de la ferme du
mousseau on est
voilà presque presque au milieu de la
forêt en tout cas on surplombe la forêt
de la colline de la revanche
c'est aussi une manière pour les élèves
de réfléchir à l'importance de
l'environnement naturel et puis la forêt
symboliquement elle permet plein
d'aventurés en termes de poésie en
termes de danse en terme d'art visuel
arbres en devenir faune florissante
cette exposition représente plusieurs
mois de travail pour les élèves
plasticien et danseurs âgés de 8 à 18
ans c'est les élèves qui ont inventé
leur technique
c'est ça qui est génial c'est que parmi
tout ce qui est comment dire toutes les
créations des élèves qui sont sortis il
ya aussi des créations technique
donc on a des découpages décollage de la
peinture de l'installation d'une danse
bien sûr beaucoup de créations
chorégraphiques alors comment comment
rendre compte d'une création
chorégraphique dans une exposition
on a des petites séries de photos donc
c'est quasiment de la chronophotographie
et puis on a aussi de la vidéo et on a
aussi du son le festival courants d'art
est un échanges interdisciplinaires
renforcée par des master classes cette
année ont été associés un chorégraphe
une musicienne est une artiste
plasticienne où mon domaine a été plutôt
au théâtre donc on était dans le
performatif et la vidéo
et après voilà ces élèves ont
réinterprété avec leurs professeurs ce
qu'ils avaient reçus en traduction
sans présenter aujourd'hui les bourgeons
ne resteront qu'un temps d'une nouvelle
réflexion les fera fleuret en mai pour
parler de la frondaison mon deuxième
invité dans ce journal et françois dany
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes de membres
pardon de l'association des amis du
musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines et c'est justement pour cette
association que vous venez de publier ce
livre l'hydro base internationale et de
l'étang de saint quentin qui revient sur
ce projet dans les années 30 de créer
sur les temps actuels de l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines une
hydre aux bases autrement dit une base
pour les hydravions capable d'atterrir
sur l'eau quand on imagine un tel projet
aujourd'hui françois dany on peut se
dire que c'est un projet fou mais à
l'époque
l'hydravion en tout cas dans les années
30 était dans un âge d'or
c'est ça c'était l'époque où les
hydravions était vue comme la modernité
notamment pour une raison très simple
c'est que l'hydravion présente pas mal
de l avantage de ne pas nécessiter de
terrain ménagers suffit de trouver une
rivière un étang et on peut se poser et
il avoue s'il avantage n'étant pas
contraint par des questions de deux
distances de décollage
mes bêtes plus lourd donc de prendre
plus de carburant donc d'aller plus loin
c'est à dire qu'à l'époque il a plus la
cote que son cousin l'avion le simple
avion voilà il a un peu plus la cote
et surtout il est très intéressant et
les vu qu'il est vue comme très
intéressant dans le cas de
franchissement de mer ou d'océan c'est
surtout ça le problème est dans les
années justement 1930 on recherche
recherche un site pour aurélie drogba le
challenge c'est traverser l'atlantique
et vous avez même des gens qui ont
inventé à l'époque l'idée de voir des
îles artificielles au milieu de
l'atlantique pour qu'on puisse se poser
et d'aller de saut de puce en sauts de
puce
jusqu aux états unis comme d'accord
quelque chose de bon c'était vraiment la
mode est à l'époque ce qui s'est posé
comme question c'est de venir faire de
paris la le point d'arrivée de transport
international donc il s'agissait de
faire une base qui permettent à la fois
de faire arriver des hydravions mais
aussi d'avoir à côté un aéroport
terrestre d'accord de façon à avoir une
espèce de up comme on dirait aujourd'hui
où les gens arrivaient de partout et
puis pouvait se poser y reprenait
l'avion ou prenez le train pour aller à
paris vous prenez prenez un taxi de
sasebo pas manquer le train pendant
l'expression et manquer le train de ce
développement l'hydravion dans l'époque
voilà à l'époque vendu à l'époque elle
est là la popularité de l'hydravion par
exemple vous voyez très bien dans les
avions de tata qui sont des relais dans
les albums de tintin qui sont parus
entre 35 et 43 sur les huit albums y en
avait cinq et les avions qui sont
montées difficiles manque c'est un
hydravion qui avaient la cote dans les
années 30 plusieurs projets sont en lice
d'ailleurs à l'époque notamment
plusieurs sur la vallée de seine c'est
sain alors ce qui se passe c'est que le
choix de faire à une hydre base est
actée par les pouvoirs publics mais
personne n'arrive à se mettre d'accord
entre les différents ministères qui sont
concernés il n'arrive pas à choisir
et il ya un gros trois projets qui trois
projets qui sont
mis en place un premier projet qui était
plutôt verville vaincre ce qui est
amusant puisque en fait c'est quasiment
l'emplacement des voici aujourd'hui
l'agrandissement du bourget est un
projet autour de saint quentin
quoi qu'on est aussi envisagé un moment
saclay donc c'est ça tourne un petit peu
en rond et ça na pas c'est ce projet qui
a été retenu du coup son projet de
l'étang de saint quentin
alors le projet n'a pas été retenu le
projet voyant que les pouvoirs publics
n'avançait pas l'aéro club de france a
voulu forcer la main et a lancé un
concours sur lequel vous avez sept
personnes qui ont répondu dont donc
l'aérienne qui proposait le bourget est
en fait l'aéro club par derrière plus ou
moins le projet de cassan qui était sur
suite saint quentin alors quel sens
pourquoi saint quentin d'une part parce
qu'ils connaissent le terrain parce que
c'est lui qui a construit des bâtiments
de météo france qui se trouve à trappes
mais il a construit bien d'autres choses
durent 24 ans et le l'homme qui est
derrière ce projet oui c'est l'homme qui
est derrière ce projet mais soutenu plus
ou moins par l'aéro club c'est clair et
donc en 37 ans 38 il ya ceux dont 38 ans
36 mhz en 36 ils ont ils font alors que
leur concours d'accord et mais l'état ne
se décide toujours pas l'état de se
décide toujours pas ayant à la fin du à
la fin des processus du concours l'état
reprend les études il dit y demande à
ses services d'étudier les différents
projets il en étudie même plusieurs
notamment parce qu'ils ont des demandes
des compagnies comme un père voyait une
cage à lowell d'installer des bases de
secours y compris et dans le coin donc
il est leur demande d'étudier tout ça et
à la fin l'état dit le bourget c'est pas
bon villepinte ça marche pas saint
quentin c'est pas pour non plus il faut
le faire à courcouronnes d'accord y'a
pas de prise de position en tout cas de
l'état il ya du lobby au touquet qui est
fait ce qu'il ya un film
d'époque le juste milieu actualité pathé
qui est réalisé pour vanter les mérites
de ce projet ce qui est intéressant
c'est que justement comme tout ça se
fait un peu en secret pour des raisons
notamment militaire entre autres et puis
pour des raisons de ne pas affoler les
gens dire que je vais acheter mon
terrain dans le coin et on pourrait
faire monter les prix
donc ça reste secret est manifestement
l'aéro club n'est pas au courant et on
retrouve une lettre où il semble qu'ils
aient eu des bruits malgré tout et on a
une lettre qui dit au sein de l'aéro
club vac assemblée il faudrait peut-être
un peu se remet si on veut pas que ça se
fasse qu'on apprenne un peu en catimini
que ça se fasse à courcouronnes et donc
à une campagne publicitaire est lancé
c'est favorable à une campagne
publicitaire on retrouve plein
d'articles dans toutes les revues
spécialisées etc etc
et il ya ce fameux film qui date de 38
donc qui est qui paraît en décembre 38
sur les écrans alors que ça fait un an
et demi que l'état a dit qu'il ne fait
ailleurs juste pour les aménageant ce
que on avance dans cet entretien j
invite les téléspectateurs à acheter
livres pour connaître les aménagements
qui était prévu dans le cadre de ce
projet pourquoi finalement il est
totalement abandonnée il ya là forcément
la guerre qui met à mal le projet mais
on va dire que c'est totalement
abandonnée au début des années 40 alors
que j'avais courcouronnes pour couronne
il lance les études et en 38
il commence à voir a demandé si les gens
seraient intéressés avant de leur
terrain mais 38 ont les aucun personne
n'est d'accord avant de son terrain
c'est évident donc ça prend du temps
en plus quand le ministre de l'air dit à
son collègue des travaux travaux publics
je voudrais faire mon amour ni drogba
du côté de courcouronnes son collègue me
répond mais vous n'y pensez pas moi j'ai
moins autoroutes du sud qui va ce qu'il
va bientôt démarrer
ça me change tout je dois tout faire
donc ça traîne encore un peu arrivent 70
39 70 39 c'est la guerre donc ça retarde
d'autant d'autant dans le même temps
vous avez les vous avez les techniques
détail d'avions qui ont considérablement
augmenté et l'hydravion des plus du tout
à l'ordre du jour en matière de
transport sur de longues distances
c'est un projet finalement dû abandonner
complètement abandonné au début des
années 1940
voilà mal
alors oui parce que malgré tout le
gouvernement de vichy essaiera de lancer
un petit peu mais bon il aura d'autres
choses à faire quoi alors on devait
passer le dans les sols pour avoir
l'idée voilà des idées de sorties et des
idées de ce qui est projeté en ce moment
dans les salles de cinéma
saint-quentinoise on va continuer
l'entretien de ce que je voulais vous
faire dire un mot sur les amis du musée
de la ville de 50 ans ning sont pas
derrière ce projet quelle est cette
association et quel type de publication
c'est une association qui est qui a été
constituée au moment où a été créé le
musée de la ville fallait mieux le musée
de saint quentin qui a pour vocation
donc d'être à la fois un soutien à
l'aiea à ce musée mais qui sert aussi un
petit peu de réflexion sur ce que c'est
que leur benne on est quand même dans
une dans un endroit où il s'est passé
des choses au niveau urbanisme les
claviers nouvelle donc il est bon de ne
pas en garder d'autres en garder un peu
le souvenir mais à la fois aussi d'avoir
une petite réflexion sur ce ce qui se
fait au niveau au niveau urbain en se
posant les bonnes questions et on
appelle type de publications ce qu'on
arrive à la fin du journal parts égales
on pourra par exemple qu'est celui là
y'en a qui a été pas qu'est paru sur sur
justement l'évolution de la ville
nouvelle en prenant des exemples dans ce
qui était à l'époque la ville nous
venons 17 communes d'accord voir comment
les espaces ont évolué et exposer les
question de pourquoi tu sais et c'est
d'essayer d'avoir une vision un peu
claire des choses dans le côté plus
historique on a sorti une petite bombe
petit jeu de cartes postales sur les sur
les écoles les mairies écoles ou et vous
fait aussi des on fait aussi des on fait
aussi pas mal de visites ont fait
visiter maujean visités soit trois fois
le territoire de saint quentin
soit des choses qui sont liées à
l'urbanisme et à l' architecture comme
la loi le riz à aubervilliers la villa
de la villa carrés à à bazoches ou des
choses comme ça il ya ces dernières
publications donc je le rappelle hydro
base internationale de l'étang de saint
quentin qui revient sur ce projet dans
les années 30 de aménager un hydro base
pardon sur l'étang de saint quentin
celui que vous voyez actuellement à
lille de loisirs merci françois d'haene
et d'autres parce qu'ils sont prêts le
plateau voilà le journal touche à sa fin
place aux 7,8 débat dans quelques
minutes au reer 11 et ses invités par
leur ont du mal être actuel chez les
forces de l'ordre rester avec nous il ya
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]